well why don't you give the audience an
overview of your autodidactic universe
theory
sure well it's um the theory is um you
know was started by in
for a couple of years of conversations
between
uh it starts roots with um
independent conversation that
lee smolin
and my my friend colleague jaron lanier
the virtual reality pioneer
we've been all three of us have been
friends for a long time so you know we
as with friends i mean john is a
computer scientist and
other things you know
multi-instrumentalists and but anyway
hopefully so you know we have our side
chats you know we talk over the years
um about things about matters that um
are scientific and not scientific and
over the years it our conversation all
coalesce into this
this um
thing about whether or not well first of
all lee and jan has over the years have
their own side conversations about
whether physical laws can can learn
um physical systems could learn their
own laws types that type of idea
and use an idea some evolutionary theory
i kind of came in at it with jaron
and also lee separately
um
thinking about fundamental theories like
you know theories of quantum gravity or
unified theories and just looking at
them structurally
um
that
the observation is that
you know
what one interesting fact is that if you
look at for example string theory
and you look at loop quantum gravity and
you look at you know
other approaches to quantum gravity
um even the original ideas of super
membrane theory the idea that the
fundamental degree of freedom is really
a membrane
not a string
and
when people try to quantize this
membrane
it
they ran into problems and they found
out that oh look at this this membrane
theory um
could be
properly quantized if you turn it into a
matrix theory so the end of the day all
these approaches to quantum gravity
pointed to
matrix theories okay and what do i mean
by matrix theories if i'm sure
you might want to want to know that but
so i'm curious so as far as i understand
i'll just tell you and then you can
correct me because it helps me learn
especially because i put myself on the
line my eagle on the line and i learn
better okay so as far as i understand
with the matrix models
you just mentioned that it solves a
particular issue but another issue is
created in that they're finite
dimensional and what you want to do is
take n to infinity
is that correct
one of the things you can do to make
contact with the continuum or of
for example
yang mills like theories which are
um
is that yeah that's right when you take
n where n is the rank of the matrix so
ever if n is two i have a two by two
matrix so when n goes infinity the rank
goes to infinity that it does reduce
back to
known theories like yang mills theories
for example
now
something that occurs to me right now as
i think about the and okay let's let's
take n to infinity would that not be
a countable infinity whereas the
infinities that we deal with with lead
groups and so on are uncountable they're
the reals so how is it that we can take
a matrix blow it up to n and get
something that's something like this
real continuum
um that's a good question um
it's similar to you know when you
you do a fourier series you know you
have a you take that sum
and
and you you you look at basically the
sum of sines and cosines and then you
when you take basically
n in that sum
to infinity that becomes the integral
sign so it's the so
it's similar to the continuum
um
hypothesis
i see i see yeah okay continue
yeah
no pun intended
um
yeah so
so in a nutshell it the observation that
i made with lee smolin and lee made with
me is that how interesting
uh matrix models seem to under underlie
a couple of what we thought to be
disparate
um
approaches to quantum gravity or
unification string theory loop point of
gravity um and other other ways um you
know random matrix models they all kind
of see
membrane theory they all point to these
matrix models so
maybe we should take more seriously that
the matrix models themselves
might
actually be
well not like gp i mean banks fishler
shanker and suskin so-called bfss
and i think ikkt named after
some japanese theorists
um
actually conjectured that m theory which
is supposed to be the you know the
unification of all string theories
um m theory or the so-called
non-perturbative definition of string
theory it was hypothesized to be a
matrix theory so
we weren't saying anything new there
but to maybe extend that extend it
beyond even m theory to say that other
approaches to quantum gravity uh might
also happen so that was one one
observation the second observation that
me john and lee made
um
was that if you look at the equations of
a matrix model
it has a semblance
to
you know um artificial some
it has a resemblance i'm not it's not
identical but it has a resemblance to
artificial neural network it resembles
it how
um
it might be useful for me to then to
write something sure please
um
so
and i'm going to be very um schematic
here i'm sure because i'm writing from
memory and i i so okay
um so just recall that an artificial
neural network basically tells me that
if i have you know a simple two layered
if i have
an input
so here's my x so x is a vector it's an
n couplet right
um
that i can it could you know that
think of each point here each dot is a
neuron that could be connected
you know in a forward way
right i can have connection
to
let me call this okay right
um right so oops sorry my bad
i don't know why it's doing that are you
able to hear any weird sounds yeah no no
no
okay
that's what i get right here so the
equation says that if i if i um there's
some output
um y
right
and there's a weight
matrix that determines how how
correlated how connected
these neurons are so for example
x1 right
if i have x x oh sorry x1 and then i
have
y1 for example right this w i j will
denote basically this is x
j
and this is y
i
right
so this basically tells me
how every neuron is connected um
you know the output is connected
to the input right
and and then of course there's some bias
term here that basically helps out with
um
um
to further basically you know to help
with bias and these connections all
right so that's
there's a long story here
um about
um neural networks
sure and um all right so
now this is very similar to um
statistical inference right if i
basically have um
in this case a line
and i tell you the slope of the line i
can adjust the slope of the line
basically to basically um fit
to fit some data right given an input um
you know the y the output will basically
map you know sort of um
maximize or
um the slope will basically maximize
in this case if you try to get the best
um standard dev you know
mean
um
you can basically
um
use this this is a multi-dimensional
version of statistical inference i see i
see okay yeah okay now
the mate um
the matrix so what i want you to take
notice of here is that
mathematically
i'm basically performing some kind of
linear transformation from one one
vector
to another vector and the weights
basically
is this transformation matrix that's one
way i like to think about it right okay
okay um
[Music]
so
in a matrix model um
what we have is something similar
not similar or again um but what we have
is
a situation where
we have
so the analogy first of all let me let
me start the analogy
the analogy is instead of having neurons
um
[Music]
that um are represented by vectors
right okay
um what with the idea here is that okay
we have matrix we have matrices
which are basically tensor products of
vectors so in other words i can for
example i could take the tensor product
of say two vectors x i
tensor x j
all right and then i can have a matrix x
i j right so likewise i can
i can have some correspondence where
the
equation of an artificial neural network
which is mapping the idea of a
perception or an artificial neuron
um is represented as a vector the idea
here is that the matrices
right
um there's a sense in which i can i can
um isolate
some components of this matrix and i
could freeze
and this freezing procedure again
isn't it's spelled out in the paper um
and it's a long story um but i just want
to spell out the basic idea sure
i can basically isolate vectors in this
thing
in this matrix model
and tell me when you say you can isolate
them
okay so let me say another thing here
you mean like how they can be decomposed
and then you just pull out one of them
yeah yeah so let's so in the matrix
models what we have is basically is let
me actually write down one of these
matrices okay
um x so it's x a
sub dimension x i
m
n
so okay what is this thing right so
basically
it's basically um let's say that i runs
from one to 3 for now right so this will
be x1
x2
x3
and then i'll still have mn here
right
so
so one thing i could do here
is assume that m n
is say
um completely diagonal
right so i can basically
make some approximation and collapse
this mn right
into
some x
so in other words here's x m n
right
and what i would now want to do is
basically
only look at these components here the
diagonal components okay i can play with
that for now and then you know just look
only at the diagonal components of this
amp no this
mn matrix and there's something that
allows you to say that it's
diagonalizable
yes there's something that allows me to
say that
right
um
and
so that's that's that's one that's one
thing you can do but the other
you know one of the things that we are
currently working on as we speak
in the follow-up paper
is exactly
how to
turn this thing into a you know um
into a bona fide
um
[Music]
into a bona fide learning architecture
similar to an artificial neural network
but the upshot
is that if you look at the equation that
i wrote um